le ministre était déjà venu en 2019 pour
lancer les jalons du projet créé à
versailles un campus d'excellence pour
les métiers du patrimoine et de
l'artisanat trois ans plus tard jean
michel blanquer air était de retour pour
se rendre compte des évolutions du
dossier une idée née à la suite de
l'incendié de notre dame de paris dans
une france en perte de ses savoir-faire
ancestraux c'est une idée généreuse
parce qu'elle consiste à partir d'une
richesse à partir d'un patrimoine que
l'on a pour aller vers la création de
l'avenir c'est à dire la transmission de
savoir faire à notre jeunesse fait de
traditions mais aussi de modernité
notamment avec les usages numériques qui
permettent de faire tant de choses quoi
comme on le voit là pour la diversité
des métiers impliqués dans un tel campus
l'objectif à présent pour le campus de
versailles a tiré ses élèves un forum
des métiers formations du patrimoine et
de l'artisanat d'excellence s'est tenu
du 10 au 12 février à la grande écurie
du roi du château de versailles pour
faire venir des jeunes averse oeil ici
des jeunes qui sont pas forcément
familier du patrimoine de la culture de
l'artisanat et qui peut-être en faire
leur destin leur réussite sur place les
collégiens lycéens et étudiants ont pu
découvrir aussi la grande diversité des
métiers au travers de cinq filières
proposées par le campus de versailles et
les possibilités sont immenses près de
300 profession comme débouchés sont des
métiers extrêmement épanouissant
c'est vraiment un ascenseur au cnca
sciences sociales qui ouvre vraiment les
voiles de l'épanouissement de la
relation on travaille tous dans la même
lignée quelle ligne est d'apprendre aux
jeunes à à trouver une formation leur
voix et puis parler avec eux de passion
ce lieu de nous retrouver ensemble c'est
vraiment un plus ça et c'est très
agréable
après deux ans d'action hors les murs le
campus de versailles est entré dans une
phase d'expérimentation depuis l'automne
il sera totalement opérationnel en 2025
un site de 6000 mètres carrés dans la
grande écurie du roi du château de
versailles